[Music]
on this sunday night child casualties
flames sweep through a packed cairo
church
claiming mostly young lives
mass evacuation measures in
spain as a rapidly growing wildfire
burns out of control
blood supply shortage only seven percent
of the population have o negative blood
types the nationwide calls for donations
as canada's reserves hit new lows and
the value of ventriloquism keep your
mouth shut when i'm talking you don't
you're not shot when i'm talking the
successful bc performer keeping a unique
art alive
global
with bara nasser
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight in egypt where a deadly
fire has left at least 41 people dead
many of them children it happened at a
coptic church in cairo it was packed
with people for sunday mass the cause is
being called accidental but the tragedy
points to a serious problem in the
country mike trolley has our top story
tonight
the scene played out again and again
shock and grief ridden survivors being
consoled by egypt's health minister
it was just before 9 a.m local time when
the fire broke out at the coptic abu
safin church in one of giza's most
densely populated neighborhoods
five thousand parishioners were
reportedly inside and when the fire
blocked the main entrance panic ensued
leading to a number of people being
trampled to death as the fire engulfed
all four floors of the church some
jumped out of windows while this man
suffered severe burns to his hands
trying to save children in the top floor
daycare
the fourth floor of the church was on
fire he says there were kids and elderly
people we saved whom we could save
we looked up and saw a lot of black
fumes in the air
officials believe most of the deaths
were caused by smoke inhalation
i saw them bringing dead people from the
upper floor says this distraught witness
suffocation suffocation all of them dead
how is this possible
egypt's interior ministry believes the
fire started after a second floor air
conditioner unit short-circuited the
country's chief prosecutor has
nevertheless ordered an investigation as
coptic christians which make up 10
percent of egypt's population have long
complained of persecution at the hands
of the muslim majority
egypt is also known for having
incredibly poor safety standards and
almost no enforcement of fire
regulations last year a fire broke out
at a garment factory in cairo killing 20
and the cause has never been confirmed
with an unknown number of children dead
the coptic church tragedy won't soon be
forgotten mike trollet global news
in armenia's capital at least three
people have now been killed while around
60 others were injured after frightening
explosions went off at a market
the blast ripped through a fireworks
storage area which then set off a large
fire that crews are still trying to
extinguish the cause of the deadly
incident remains unknown meanwhile
search and rescue teams are still
digging through the rubble looking for
more people who might be trapped beneath
in northeastern spain around 1500 people
have now been forced to flee their homes
in the region after another large
wildfire declared on saturday rapidly
grew overnight
[Applause]
[Music]
around 300 firefighters are fighting the
out of control blaze that's already
burned around 8 000 hectares in less
than 24 hours forcing evacuation orders
on eight villages it's just one of
spain's many recent infernos with 43
large wildfires recorded this year
that's its highest number in the last
decade as drought and record-breaking
heat continue to swamp much of europe
author salman rushdie is said to be on
the road to recovery after being stabbed
several times during a public appearance
friday rashthi was removed from a
ventilator yesterday and was able to
talk and joke according to his agent
today rashi's son posted a family
statement saying though his
life-changing injuries are severe his
usual feisty and defiant sense of humor
remains intact the 75 year old has a
damaged liver severed nerves and may
lose an eye the attack has been met with
outrage and condemnation particularly
from those in the literary world
i was stunned
i was shocked but i i wasn't surprised
do you know because
because he's lived with that threat for
so long
um the fact that he was attacked and the
fact that this is the environment that
we're living in that has become more and
more
divided
much more dangerous to to voice an
opinion
never mind as a writer
rushdie has faced death threats for more
than 30 years over his book the satanic
verses some muslims consider the themes
about the prophet muhammad blasphemous a
24 year old new jersey man was arrested
at the scene
days after the fbi search for top secret
files at mar-a-lago donald trump's
potential legal problems seem to keep
piling up the former u.s president now
claims authorities seized executive
privilege material and is demanding them
back while a spokesman says trump had a
standing order that documents taken to
his florida home were deemed
declassified as jennifer johnson reports
those claims aren't holding up
former u.s president donald trump and
his allies say any top-secret documents
brought to his florida estate had been
declassified but the fbi received a tip
that wasn't true which led to the
seizure of 11 boxes of still highly
classified material from trump's home
last week while sitting presidents do
have the authority to declassify a
document through a formal legal process
there's no indication trump did that a
former president has no declassification
authority and the idea that 18 months
after the fact donald trump trump could
simply announce well i'm you know
retroactively declassifying or whatever
i took home had the effect of
declassifying them
is absurd there is still no explanation
from trump or his team as to why the
president took the top secret documents
to his home it's hard for me to
understand a legitimate national
security reason why the former president
should have the documents he appears to
have been holding at mar-a-lago the
question now was the president simply
careless or was there criminal intent
trump could face charges as serious as
espionage and the illegal retention of
government property that would
disqualify trump from ever running for
public office again
but trump supporters were quick to rally
around the former president gathering
outside mar-a-lago this weekend many
republicans like trump say this is just
another witch hunt to hurt their party's
2024 presidential front-runner the white
house is dismissing those claims saying
the department of justice is an
independent government agency we do not
interfere we do not get briefed we do
not get involved as trump mounts his
possible legal defense insiders are now
blaming white house lawyers for not
generating the paperwork to change the
classification markings on the documents
and boxes meanwhile some democrats in
congress are calling for an
investigation to determine if there's
been any damage to america's national
security
jennifer johnson global news washington
to taiwan now where less than two weeks
after nancy pelosi's visit triggered
china's fury another unannounced u.s
congressional delegation has touched
down the team of four u.s congress
members led by one senator was welcomed
in taipei today a statement says they
will meet with taiwan's president and
other senior leaders on a two-day visit
to discuss security and trade issues
their arrival comes after china's
military concluded some of its most
aggressive drills near taiwan in
response to pelosi's visit to the island
beijing regards as its own
tomorrow marks one year since the
taliban recaptured afghanistan's capital
kabul by the end of august 2021 the
final u.s troops had left the country
since then international sanctions
against the regime have helped drive the
afghan economy into a downward spiral
the u.n says millions of people face
hunger or worse as redmond shannon
reports solving that problem could mean
the west having to confront a difficult
dilemma
the malnutrition ward at this cabo
hospital has 40 beds they are all full
abeda comforts her 10 month old son
we are so upset we are depressed my
husband feels ashamed
he said my son is dying in front of my
eyes but i'm not capable of doing
anything in afghanistan the biggest
cause of malnutrition is the underlying
poverty rates canadian melanie galvin is
unicef's head of nutrition in
afghanistan i think we need in the
longer term we're still going to need a
great deal of funding to just
treat these children
funds are at the core of so many
problems in afghanistan in a plea for
humanitarian aid in the spring the
united nations said almost half the
population faces hunger
when the us-led forces left one year ago
the west refused to recognize the
taliban government so development aid
and international support dried up
leaving a massive gap in the aid-reliant
economy most of the people they don't
have bank accounts they don't have
savings
they spend whatever they get in their
salaries so when the salaries were cut
people could not
afford their families afghan political
analyst abdul hai khannat says the
situation has stabilized but poverty
remains a serious issue afghanistan's 9
billion u.s dollars in foreign reserves
would undoubtedly help but that cash is
currently out of reach of the taliban
mostly sitting in american banks the u.s
and the taliban are negotiating
washington looking for assurances from
kabul that the money won't end up in
corrupt hands president joe biden has
also set 3.5 billion of it aside
potentially as compensation for the
families of september 11th victims it's
just
politically odious for any u.s president
to you know shrink wrap billions of
dollars and send it back into the hands
of a a central bank that is ultimately
controlled by the taliban afghans are
often divided on issues but on this they
are generally united the mentality of
normal afghans is that this is our money
and it should be given to the god to to
to us in
we know how to do this
as the west dangles that cash it also
wants to see progress on human rights in
afghanistan in particular on the ban on
girls from attending high schools
the recent killing of al-qaeda leader
ayman al-zawahiri in kabul only further
complicates negotiations in a tug of war
between ideologies it is as ever regular
people who suffer redmond shannon global
news london
coming up cross country calls for donors
amid concerns over canada's depleting
blood supply
the canadian blood services is calling
on more people to donate right now
national inventory levels are low for
six out of the eight blood types the
organization says the number of
canadians who donate regularly has
dropped since the start of the pandemic
leading to the smallest donor base in a
decade amber friday reports
canadian blood services say they are
seeing a shortage in supply of blood
donation nearly 57 000 appointments need
to be filled for sufficient blood supply
the organization is hoping more
first-time donors will help fill the gap
it's very empowering it's something that
you can do and when you leave the clinic
you leave with your head held high to
know that i just saved the life during
the summer months gracie says there is
typically a decline in blood donations a
lot of that's due to summer activities
and summer weather there is no
substitute for human blood and
you know and it never gets to take a
vacation or a summer holiday and the
warmer weather brings an increase in
need which is why gracie says the
universal o negative donor is needed now
more than ever in times of an emergency
and we don't have time to figure out
what that patient's blood type is we use
o-negative and funny with o-negative
it's very it's on the rare side so only
seven percent of the population have
o-negative blood type so if you are no
negative you definitely need to come
donate daryl lind has donated his blood
over 500 times and encourages others to
give it a try
it doesn't hurt
it only takes an hour every time
and you never know if you need it
one hour from the time you walk in the
door until the time you leave with only
10 minutes spent collecting blood blood
i am terrified of needles
and i'm in donating about once a week
it's very easy process they have free
chips and cookies there's ac
you're giving the gift of life and it's
just so important
amber friday global news halifax
canadian blood services also faces
dwindling plasma donations important for
many medical procedures now it's looking
into whether paying donors may help on
friday the agency said it's now talking
with commercial companies on how to
overcome a shrinking donor base unpaid
plasma donations make up 15 percent of
important immunoglobulin supplies the
agency says it needs at least 50 percent
to meet demand but the practice of
paying donors is still banned in bc
ontario and quebec
ahead still haunted by the death of
amanda todd an rcmp officer who worked
the case speaks out for the first time
a former british columbia rcmp officer
who testified at the trial of the man
convicted of sextorting amanda todd is
still haunted by the case more than a
decade later andrea shattuck says she
still clearly remembers her first
meeting with todd and the concern she
felt at how little was being done to
stop the person responsible for the
teen's torment ramina daya has this
exclusive report
retired coquitlam rcmp constable andrea
shattuck vividly remembers amanda todd
14 at the time storming off to her
bedroom when she told the teen to get
off facebook for her safety moments
later i knocked on her door and she told
me to come in and i found a totally
different
child in that room
you know i told her i understood
the draw to be on facebook and stuff
like that it's kind of addictive
um and i asked her why why do you keep
creating all these profiles and why do
you keep adding people that you don't
know in real life and
she just said i'm lonely
amanda the victim of sexual blackmail by
an online predator for years
pornographic images of the teen sent to
family classmates and teachers it's now
november 2011. shattuck tells global
news she refers the file to bc ice the
rcmp's elite child exploitation unit
they came back with he just is very good
at what he does he's masked his i.p
address
and
we there's no way to figure out who's
doing this i was
surprised to put it mildly so i fully
trusted that they had
um the technology
and the training to handle something
like this
i was
probably that was the first time in my
career where i felt disillusioned with
my job
amanda's file closed a year later
october 2012 catastrophic news
shattuck in new york when she finds out
amanda killed herself i was powerless to
protect her
[Music]
weeks before amanda took her life she
shared her story of blackmail torment
and depression in a haunting youtube
video viewed by millions worldwide that
video
is what
kicked everybody into gear put pressure
to reopen that investigation
but in my mind amanda
had she just committed suicide and not
made that video
she probably would have just faded into
the background
and
koban might have gotten away with it
so
i think she's a hero
rcmp spokesperson sergeant chris manseau
tells global news bcice worked
extensively with coquitlam rcmp on
amanda's case before she died we are
awaiting further details from the
mounties the trial now over aidan cobin
will be sentenced soon shattuck wanting
to leave the world with this
most of all
i want them to remember she was just a
little girl
she was not responsible for what
happened to her
romina daya global news
next giving ventriloquism a voice meet
the performer trying to keep the art
form alive
ventriloquism is one of those
performance acts that harkens back to a
different time the popular charlie
mccarthy show with edgar bergen aired
more than 60 years ago during the golden
era of ventriloquism since then there
have been few big acts but as jay durant
explains a british columbia man is
trying to keep the art form alive
orders are coming in so don bryan's
bringing back an old skill he learned as
a kid then i cut these from just from
aluminum these ventriloquists talk and
words getting around that he's one of
the only people who can still make a
hand-carved professional wood puppet
when soon you're lying soon
detailing is the hard part it's been
almost 70 years since his first creation
just a short time before his first paid
gig as a 15 year old i was thrilled i
got paid five bucks
here without losing your mouth
watching performances on the ed sullivan
show was what got him hooked for the
longest time this was just a part-time
job for brian until he hit a rough patch
in the mid 80s things fell apart for me
i lost my job lost my house lost my
girlfriend lost my car
everything went
better that's when he turned pro and
he's been doing regular shows ever since
he's open for dolly parton bb king and
once had to win over a tough crowd as
the opening act for eddie murphy in
vancouver
he got some laughs that night and a very
brief shout out from the comedian when
he took the stage so he had a
ventriloquist say hell was he and they
all went yeah he went okay so moving on
lost the luggage right now at age 80
brian is still performing in demand on
cruise ships
you didn't get yours either
i'll
which means some rehearsal time at home
with these dummies and the star of the
show noseworthy yeah keep your mouth
shut when i'm talking you don't you're
not shy
a lifetime in show business goes on
because he isn't ready to let the
curtain fall on an amazing career just
yet i love i love being
on stage doing my show you know having
fun with the crowd and getting the
laughs and
i enjoy that i don't see an end to that
i don't think that was any good
suffering are you wearing that big ring
again no well i'm sitting on something i
know jay durant global news
hilarious and that is tonight's global
national tonight's year canada is payto
lake in alberta's banff national park we
love seeing your canada please keep
sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching pharah nasser will
be at the anchor desk tomorrow have a
great night
[Music]
you